tena on en attendait beaucoup mais c'est
l'histoire d'un rendez vous manqué
février 2011
après la première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale le sénat est saisi du projet
de loi sur la bioéthique un texte qui
concerne aussi bien les enfants nés d'un
don de gamètes à la recherche de leurs
origines ou les couples infertiles ayant
recours à une mère porteuse à l'étranger
les évolutions de la société oblige le
parlement à prendre position et les
attentes sont fortes
ce conditionnel de l'audace et je suis
constatée ces dernières années que
souvent on s'est créé le le sénat qui
est le plus en pointe ou moderne plus
souffert pour palais du luxembourg deux
tendances vont se poser au sein du
groupe majoritaire
les progressistes et les conservateurs
gynécologue alain milon et le rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
il incarne l'ailé progressiste de l'ump
me semble que tu toi cette sortie
d'action nationale n'a pas fait de
progrès par rapport à l'existant est le
nom
marie thérèse hermange appartient la
frange conservatrice de l'ump
la vision de la bioéthique est à
l'opposé de celle d'alain milon du lieu
d'où la souffrance aura une pensée
différents projets c'est d'essayer de
proposer la fois les compétitions avec
la raison ce que nous dit la raison d'un
scientifique des dames vue juridique
un mois durant les sénateurs ont
auditionné chercheurs juristes médecins
ou encore philosophe un sujet majeur va
être au coeur des débats la recherche
sur l'embryon n'est pas consensus de loi
sur ce plan va vraiment en retard
européen peut parler voici leurs auteurs
aujourd'hui cette recherche est
interdite en france mais des dérogations
existent
une quarantaine de laboratoires
travaillent sur des embryons congelés
conçu dans le cadre de fécondation in
vitro est donnée à la recherche par des
couples infertiles qui n'ont plus de
projet d'enfant en première lecture les
députés ont maintenu cette interdiction
ce matin le sénat reçoit quatre
chercheurs qui travaillent sur l'embryon
humain pour trouver des thérapies à des
maladies neurodégénératives comme la
maladie de parkinson
la législation pour ces chercheurs la
décision des députés de maintenir le
statu quo n'est pas satisfaisant en
effet il est difficile d'obtenir une
dérogation pour travailler sur l'embryon
ou bien on a la ferme conviction que
cette recherche n'est pas éthique n'est
pas moral et on l'interdît ce qu'ont
fait certains pays
l'irlande la pologne ou bien on a la
conviction qu'il ya là une voie de
recherche qui est susceptible
susceptible d'aboutir à des applications
thérapeutiques ou l'encouragent
on la soutient et donc on l'autorisé nom
de bâts en même temps dire une chose et
son contraire
l'attitude de la france peut sembler
hypocrite à l'interdît la recherche sur
l'embryon tout en permettant des
dérogations exceptionnelles vous dire
moi peu sûr là dessus hypocrisie majeur
mais alors une peau convie à un point
non enfin si demain la recherche new
dawn est issu des cellules souches
embryonnaires
le traitement de l'infarctus mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
vous diriez aux étrangers comment vous
avez fait s'il vous plaît évite la
recherche sur l'embryon suscite un débat
éthique pour une partie de l'opinion
notamment les catholiques l'embryon est
un être humain dès le commencement de sa
guise selon la fondation jérôme lejeune
un lobby anti avortement on ne doit pas
toucher à l'embryon l'histoire
helvétique depuis 17 ans et celle d'une
dégradation
on sent aussi du statut de l'humain en
fait la plupart de ceux qui s'occupent
de cette question de l'embryon ont aboli
toutes distances avec l'embryon ils ont
établi envers lui un rapport de
possessivité et de violence sont arrivés
l'embryon à sa dimension biologique pour
la priver de son histoire personnelle
est mis à disposition du plus offrant
dans le camp opposé marc peschanski
directeur de recherche à l'inserm
travaille sur des cellules souches
embryonnaires grâce à une dérogation
exceptionnelle dans son laboratoire en
région parisienne il est fait de trouver
des thérapies ya certaines maladies
génétiques
mon objectif c'est de défendre la vie je
fais que les associations qui prétendent
défendre les embryons s'appelle comme ça
les associations défense pour la vie moi
je pense que c'est nous qui défendons la
vie et que la combattent
il la combattre parce qu'on nous
empêchant de travailler en essayant de
bloquer la recherche
il ne faut que faire perdre des vies au
sénat la recherche sur l'embryon
interpelle les membres de la commission
des affaires sociales
faut-il continuer à l'interdire ou bien
l'autoriser tout en l'encadrant
la question divise les sénateurs se
cherche à comprendre certaines essences
pour alain milon la question est
tranchée
il faudrait changer la loi afin
d'autoriser la recherche sur l'embryon
le fait de l'interdire et d'autoriser à
titre exceptionnel ou sous certaines
conditions ça s'arrange message visible
par des chercheurs n'a pas des
entreprises
un jeune un post post doc qui veut se
lancer là dedans
pour l'instant c'est interdit n'est
autorisé sous certaines conditions
ou mieux coller aux états unis ou en
suisse face à face aux charges que de
rester en france
un point de vue que ne partage pas marie
thérèse hermange pour elles l'embryon
est sacrée
si on pousse à l'embryon de toute façon
on touche à la dignité principe de la
dignité de l'homme
je ne vois pas comment on pourra
continuer à avoir ce principe dans notre
code civil et au fil des discussions
certains vont regretter la frilosité de
la loi votée en première lecture par les
députés
moi je suis très frappé par l'esprit
craintif peureux qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui et en particulier sur les
questions bioéthiques pense que c'est
fait d'un peuple vieux qui ne cherchent
plus à se protéger et certainement qui
n'est plus qu'à prendre des risques se
trouve un peu l'équivalent de la mort
d'une civilisation de la mort d'un grand
pays enfin bon
cette frilosité que regrette elisabeth
badinter on va la retrouver sur un autre
sujet de société
l'aide médicale à la procréation pour
les couples homosexuels
la semaine dernière je recevais un
couple de professeurs de faculté à
strasbourg deux femmes ensemble depuis
14 ans qui me disent on a bien réfléchi
on a envie d'un enfant tu que de soule
où habite un couple d'homosexuels hommes
et l'un d'entre eux acceptent de donner
son nom accepte de donner son sperme
je suis un peu pas confiance les envois
en belgique comme la france a souvent
fait la france a souvent fait sans
d'exporter sa souffrance on l'a fait
pour les ivg et aujourd'hui on le sait
pour panne autre chose
et donc plutôt que d'analyser au cas par
cas ces demandes ce qui serait risqué
l'honorable et guigne on dit tu ne seras
points et ça cette espèce de tout il est
interdit ne paraît pas éthiquement
acceptable parce qu'on discute même
temps avec les couples français
et quand on met en devanture tout il est
interdit dans le back room toute idée
permis jeu là pourquoi les couples
homosexuels robots peuvent se faire
inséminer en belgique
pourquoi quand tu as des soucis aux
états unis pour une grossesse pour
autrui on crée on crée des lois pour les
pauvres et les riches transgresse ce que
j'avais dit quand on m'a demandé notre
reporter
c'est qu'on puisse disputer tous les
sujets cet accord se détermineront et
qu'on puisse discuter de tous les sujets
sans attaches locales afin que chacun
puisse exprimer puis le vent de
l'histoire
autre sujet qui divise les sénateurs la
question du diagnostic prénatal en
première lecture l'assemblée nationale a
voulu mettre fin au dépistage
systématique de la trisomie 21 chez les
femmes d'enfants
car si le test s'avère positif la
plupart des femmes décident d'avorter
l'amendement du député jean leonetti
prévoit que le médecin ne doit proposer
le dépistage qu'aux femmes enceintes qui
présentent des risques de porter un
enfant trisomique une rédaction qui
satisfait la fondation jérôme lejeune la
vérité que d'abonnement les vêtir enfin
réglé et le rôle des médecins qui appose
en fait déjà un dépistage en population
captive et qui a créé ce site là dessus
une rente sans limite au profit des
laboratoires
huit cent mille femmes enceintes
annuellement chez qui on développe un
fantasme ciblées pour lequel on trouvait
des tests le risque de donner naissance
à un enfant trisomique et pour
lesquelles l'assurance navy finances
sans broncher un budget massif et
efficace 100 millions par an je vais
étonner comme vous de voir qu'on a peur
des vins plus conséquent sur l'eugénisme
positif ou négatif
en tout cas remboursés par la sécurité
sociale alors que parallèlement comme
vous l'avez dit bien des tests
commerciaux et est-ce qu'ils sont un
marché conséquent mais au sein de la
communauté médicale cela crée un débat
éthique aux dépens de petits tracteurs
la formation qui n'a donneront la
donnera pas est-ce qu'on choisira les
femmes de plus de 35 ans les autres on
leur donnera pas d'information de la
plupart des trisomiques naissent de
femmes de moins de 35 ans au nom de quoi
laisser ce degré de liberté aux médecins
au même titre les médecins demandent pas
le droit de tuer les médecins demandent
pas le droit de choisir à qui il donne
l'information et donc crois qu'il faut
absolument retenir à tout
avant ma mort c'est très difficile de
légiférer parce que le décalage vient du
fait que dans une loi on ne peut pas
transposer ses positions morales et
religieuses que l'on a tous après 28
auditions la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat s'apprête à modifier
en profondeur le texte de l'assemblée
188 d'amendements ont été déposés à la
réunion hebdomadaire du groupe ump le
ministre de la santé xavier bertrand
rappelle la position du gouvernement sur
la recherche sur l'embryon
al'inverse du rapporteur le ministre
estime la situation actuelle
satisfaisante crois pas qu'elles
attendent de révolution quand bioéthique
pourquoi on le voit bien notre pression
jour de l'interdiction avec dérogation
permet à la recherche française et
pouvoir penser à travailler avant s'est
il aussi les avancées importantes à
l'assemblée nationale sur ce test qui
nous permettent aujourd'hui de donner de
la visibilité aux chercheurs mais en
maintenant nos passeurs de savoir que
rapportera des conditions qu'il porte
depuis longtemps je vous cache pas que
je respecte je n'ai pas palpable à tout
mais avant de débattre dans l'hémicycle
la commission des affaires sociales se
réunit le but examiner les amendements
déposés sur le texte voté par les
députés en présence de nora berra la
secrétaire d'état à la santé
donc nous allons examiner aujourd'hui le
projet de loi 103 104 adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale
la bataille va tourner autour du
maintien ou non de l'amendement du
député léonetti qui vise à supprimer le
caractère systématique du dépistage de
la trisomie 21
une phrase va faire polémique
concrètement si on s'est pris c'est
simon qui ont été passées par la
généralisation du dépistage prénatal
entre guitare batterie que de la fille
de libreville ont fait de la
généralisation obligations on passe une
légalisation face à marie thérèse
hermange
une partie de la commission oppose le
droit à l'information des parents
deuxièmement le premier sur le
territoire jusqu'à l'insertion
normalement mais l'objectif c'est un
seul village pour rendre la loi telle
qu'elle existe et ce à travers de la
maman intégré dans l'assemblée nationale
on a également procédé à un recul par
avoir la liberté dans son vin ce qui
représente 11
lee et défendant la loi de 2002 sur le
droit des patients s'est avéré
finalement la commission revient sur la
rédaction de l'assemblée nationale après
le diagnostic prénatal des débats vont
avoir lieu autour de la recherche sur
l'embryon
on ne veut pas au terme des discussions
la présidente de la commission métaux
voile amendement d'alain milon qui vise
à autoriser la recherche amendement
adopté à une forte majorité le sénat va
à l'encontre de l'assemblée nationale et
du gouvernement la recherche sur
l'embryon est autorisée mais elle sera
fortement encadré sur certains points
extrêmement important on se rend compte
que le clivage n'est pas droite gauche
mais qu'il s'agit vraiment d'une
interrogation d'une interpellation de
chacun de nous face à nous mêmes et que
l'on n'arrive pas forcément avec une
position définitivement arrêté
autorisation de la recherche sur
l'embryon diagnostic prénatal levée de
l'anonymat des donneurs de gamètes
au terme de cette première étape le
sénat a profondément modifié le texte de
l'assemblée nationale dans un sens plus
progressive
religion a fait avancer les sujets ça
c'est clair donc maintenant on va
rentrer en séance on aura certainement
des débats d'animaux très élevé au point
et scientifique au point de vue
intellectuel et au point de vue moral et
des décisions qui seront prises qui jeu
soit iront dans le sens un commission
présentera premier débat dans
l'hémicycle le diagnostic prénatal de la
trisomie 21 temps personnes handicapées
n'est pas forcément synonyme de
souffrance bien de fois nous entendons
des parents dit j'ai quatre enfants
mais ces sept enfants handicapés qui ma
pensée le plus de joie de vivre
conviennent fans aux entendants
entendant dire ça pour vous
l'enfant il sacré passe avant tout à
partir de l'instant même où il est conçu
et quoi qu'il advienne
ensuite je respecte cette position
simplement ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est l'impasse que vous faites sur
rennes la souffrance des parents qui
voient que l'avenir de leurs enfants ne
sera pas celui qu'ils avaient escompté
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettre un bulletin bleus à l'issue des
débats le sénat supprime la disposition
de l'assemblée nationale sur le
diagnostic prénatal
dans la même veine il autorise la
recherche sur l'embryon comme le
préconisait la commission des affaires
sociales pour l'adoption 142 2 contre
187 l'amendement du ministre de la santé
n'est pas adoptée est une claque pour le
gouvernement
enfin dans la soirée coup de théâtre au
détour d'un amendement déposé par les
socialistes le sénat autorise l'aide
médicale à la procréation pour les
couples de femmes homosexuelles pour
l'opposition c'est un succès inespéré
c'est une victoire parce qu'elle
reconnaît enfin la possibilité pour des
femmes homosexuelles de pouvoir porter
je veux dire est de pouvoir avoir un
enfant cette discrimination était tout à
fait inacceptable ce qui est du domaine
du possible scientifiquement et
techniquement ne doit pas ouvrir toutes
les portes possibles et toutes là toutes
les
les situations que l'imagination humaine
pourrait pourrait avoir pour ce qui est
d'un moment 146 le sénat n'a pas adopté
sur de nombreux points le sénat
s'opposent au gouvernement notamment en
autorisant la recherche sur l'embryon
vous semez le ministre de la santé n'a
pas dit son dernier mot
la mp du fait d'un amendement est donc
ouverte aujourd'hui du fait du vote de
la loi au sénat aux couples homosexuels
ce n'est pas possible nous reviendrons
sur cette disposition
et la deuxième chose également c'est
qu'on a changé avec le vote du texte de
la commission de système nous sommes
passés d'une interdiction avec
dérogations à un principe d'autorisation
ce n'est pas la position du gouvernement
je n'ai à redire que en ce qui concerne
les différentes navettes ne soyez pas
étonnés si la position du gouvernement
est cohérente pour revenir à ce point
non mais je tiens quand même aussi tout
simplement à vous le dire
et à lire et à lire publiquement parce
que je voulais indiqué je pense qu'il ya
eu des avancées intéressantes
d'apprendre la commission des affaires
sociales qui ont été reprises par
l'assemblée du sénat
donc oui sur l'ensemble c'est un maxime
semble équilibré et qui me semble
correspondre
à la volonté de d'une majorité de
sénateurs
on est sans illusion si parce que hélas
le ministre a été parfaitement clair il
a dit que ça ne lui convenait pas et
qu'il ferait tout pour revenir accès en
seconde lecture
quand même incroyable en l'écoutant je
disais les finalement à quoi servent les
parlementaires puisque le gouvernement a
la prétention de faire la loi quelle que
soit notre vote
donc on verra bien comment résisteront
notamment les députés qui nous avait
proposé un texte qui était un texte
rétrograde qui m'aurait un petit peu on
peut dès à présent la loire part à
l'assemblée nationale pour l'examen en
seconde lecture
et comme prévu les députés reviennent à
leur position initiale
exit l'aide médicale à la procréation
pour les homosexuels et la recherche sur
l'embryon est à nouveau interdite
retour au sénat le ton monte en
commission des affaires sociales
bon ceci étant dit tous les airs sert
jamais encore vu la semaine dernière et
son vent de nous par contre les
décisions de l'assemblée nationale et
tous les chercheurs chercheurs français
les chercheurs interne à taux ne
comprennent plus rien à prouver on est
complètement ridiculiser on voit bien
que là il s'agit de répondre et bien aux
directives
alors ça veut dire si je suis
provocateur du vatican si je suis
provocation dans la salle le vc si je
suis pauvre 14e di de monseigneur vingt
trois
cette fois les débats sont plus haut le
car les positions se sont affirmés
l'opposition accuse les sénateurs de la
majorité de légiférer sous influence de
l'église catholique commence à suffire
aussi à une religion mais on n'est pas
obligé de suivre ceux qui la dévie oui
oui on n'est pas obligé hier toute une
série de télé son trône et aussi aux
cicatrices et reprenne sa cible les
catholiques qui sont ici développé à
travers l'amendement présenté par
malheureusement ont la totale liberté de
vol et d'opinion service ou sans moi qui
me fait dire que je crois effectivement
que la vie est un don que cette vie
commence au moment de la série initiale
qui se constituent que sept cellules des
zetas temps peut-être en mouvement et
peut donner naissance à une vie même et
qu'à partir de là effectivement tu
considères que nous n'avons pas offert
au sénat la frange des sénateurs ump
opposés à la recherche sur l'embryon se
mobilisent le but revenir à
l'interdiction avec dérogations
au sein du groupe ump les pressions sont
fortes pour faire changer d'avis les
récalcitrants c'est vrai qu'il ya des
pressions quelquefois un petit peu
difficile et puis quelquefois un petit
peu plus soft mais c'est vrai que on
sent bien qu un acquis sont très
passionnés par ce et c'est vrai qu'on
peut le comprendre des convictions
profondes s'efforce fonctionnement on
s'entraîne des patients dans l'hémicycle
la tension est palpable
patrick ollier le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement suit les
débats de très près pour alain milon
c'est la dernière occasion de se faire
entendre
je crains les régimes où la loi dicte la
vérité scientifique
moi je train les régimes où la science
serait supérieur au droit
moi je crains c'est régime là un nouvel
amendement est déposée par jean claude
gaudin le président du groupe ump
c'est jean-louis lorrain qui le présente
dans l'hémicycle président madame la
ministre effectivement et la lourde
charge de présenter cet amendement 51
objectif de l'amendement durcir les
conditions de l'interdiction de la
recherche sur l'embryon juste à dire que
au kazoo évidemment mais c'est
probablement ce qui va se passer
l'amendement du président gaudin était
accepté il a interdit la recherche sur
les cellules souches points ce qui est
extrêmement important dans le texte
si le texte de monsieur gaudin est
adopté on a interdit toutes les toutes
les recherches sans exception
la séance est suspendue
une interruption de séance est demandée
par le groupe ump
le gouvernement rappelle à l'ordre les
derniers récalcitrants
ils sont seize 16 sénateurs à s'opposer
à l'interdiction avec dérogations le
gouvernement souhaite obtenir un vote
conforme pour que le sujet soit
définitivement réglée en séance publique
vous avez bloqué le débat est là vous
donner véritablement un signe très
négatif à l'ensemble du monde
scientifique car vous ne voulez
absolument plus ouvrir le débat sur ce
point là fut complètement suffoquer et
vous aurez du mal à expliquer ça aux
scientifiques et quelles que soient les
positions religieuses des uns et des
autres il s'agit d'un progrès concernant
les vivants vous donner un mauvais signe
à la recherche est un bon signe à ceux
qui défilent avec des pancartes pour
réclamer un statut de l'embryon nous
coûte 1 sera ouvert que quelques
résidents ont saisi
bondues suffrages exprimés 325 pour
l'adoption sont 64 contre l'adoption 161
le sénat a donc adopté la recherche sur
l'embryon est donc interdite à trois
voix près un vote très serré qui reflète
les divisions des sénateurs même s'il a
réussi à faire passer le diagnostic
prénatal
pour le rapporteur alain milon c'est un
jour de deuil pour la recherche
ça complique énormément le travail de
chercheur et ça à mon avis facilite le
travail de ceux qui sont contre ce genre
de recherche en première lecture c'est
pas les groupes qui ont voté mais les
sénateurs présents et mobilisé sur le
sujet en deuxième lecture il ya
probablement eu des des pressions faites
par les uns et par les autres on a vu
quelques articles intéressés et
passionnés dans la presse en particulier
qui ont fait que les groupes politiques
se sont à nouveau mobilisés et ont fait
voter leurs membres en fonction de deux
directives qui sont donnés par les
présidents de groupe
pour marie thérèse hermange c'est une
victoire personnelle même si la loi ne
va pas aussi loin qu'elle l'aurait
espéré fait idée longtemps portée j'ai
présenté 122 amendement il y en a cinq
antennes qui ont été adoptées qui sont
venus le texte de la commission
oui une certaine victoire dans la mesure
où il ya eu des revirements et notamment
sur la recherche sur l'embryon puisque
le texte pose le principe symbolique de
l'interdiction de la recherche
en même temps il pose aussi un certain
nombre de dérogations mais il était
important de manifester cette
interdiction
alain millions et marie thérèse hermange
ont tous deux voté contre cette loi mais
pour des raisons différentes
alain milon estime que c'est un texte
rétrograde marie thérèse hermange pense
qu'il aurait pu aller plus loin au final
ce texte frileux ne satisfait personne
cette occasion ratée de modifier en
profondeur la loi de bioéthique laisse
un goût d'inachevé